hi my name is alvin i am a tasty
producer and
i love steak steak is by far my most
favorite thing to eat
and cook in the entire world it's
indulgent
it's beautiful it's juicy and when it's
done right it is
impressively delicious and i just want
to share my love of steak with you guys
so i'll be cooking you guys three steak
dishes for you to make at home whether
you have five minutes
50 minutes or even five hours to make
something special so
let's get cooking whether you're super
busy or really lazy you got five minutes
to cook for this scenario we'll be
cooking hanger steak
so hanger steak is a really nice cut of
steak it's super super tender
has nice marbling cooks really quickly
if you want you could also swap this out
for a skirt steak
first things first you always have to
prep put your pan on start heating it
right away make sure you use a vegetable
oil measure out your soy sauce
and your honey in the same bowl this
will eventually be
the finishing glaze for the steak season
your steak liberally with salt we're
gonna do pepper later season both sides
grab your cutting board and your knife
take the plate that you'll be eating off
of
and throw some greens on it i like
arugula you can use whatever greens you
want
this pan is you know super hot but i'm
not a rapper
all right time to cook i'm gonna lay in
this beautiful steak
cool this steak is gonna cook for about
one and a half minutes per side
i'm gonna be cooking the steak to medium
rare all right let's give it another
check
oh look at that crust if there's any
gray area on a steak
that's just untapped potential right
there i think it's time to flip
oh man to finish we're gonna add in the
soy honey glaze that we made it's going
to reduce
and get all nice and beautiful look at
that
this is where it gets sexy shake that
around a bit
it glazes and bubbles like that yo
that's nice
i think it's pretty much done so we're
gonna take it out to rest
rest it for about one to one and a half
minutes it's like the toughest minute of
this entire process i promise but it'll
all be worth it
see where we're at it's looking nice
just look at that piece for me
oh this good it's nice and pink all
right time to plate so
you might have some extra sauce in this
pan from that glaze
we're not going to let that go to waste
spread it in a nice little
pool for the steak to sit on then
we're going to get all under the knife
and go over here you also want to make
sure you fend out a bit too
some pepper all these steak juices
a little bit of salad dressing and there
you have it
this is a five-minute soy honey hanger
steak
with some arugula on the side
maybe you have a bit longer to cook like
50 minutes to an hour so for the second
time scenario we will be cooking a
bone-in rib eye probably one of the most
popular cuts of steak
look for really really nice marbling
which is fat in between the muscle
ribeye is comprised of the eye area as
well as
the cap area that's the best part of the
rib eye we're going to be doing what's
called a reverse
sear first cook it in an oven at a very
low temperature
and then you sear it in the pan first
thing always got to season your steak so
a nice amount of salt gotta be pretty
generous with it because
kind of want to have enough seasoning
for everything we're gonna put it on
a baking sheet with a rack because the
rack will allow air to circulate
underneath
this goes in the oven for about 40
minutes
until internal temperature will read 125
degrees
and we'll cook the rest of it i love
garlic bread i love steak
why not have them together you got some
time make a meal might as well do it
first thing we're going to do we're
going to let our butter hang over here
to get really soft
mince some garlic we're going to
actually do this trick coarse salt
press like crush it use the salt as like
an abrasive
so it gets even finer and more like a
paste all right
i'm gonna chop up some parsley for some
green we're gonna grate some cheese
it's worth having two cheeses because in
your garlic bread it's gonna taste a lot
better
and we're gonna cut our bread in half
let's make this thing
the same bowl i shredded the cheese in
i'm throwing the butter
put in all this nice parsley garlic
we're just gonna give it a really nice
mix nice and generous
you ever get garlic bread with too much
bread not enough garlic
i'm here to tell you that you can do
what you want so we're going to wrap
these in foil
is a wait for the steak to be done and
we'll keep cooking
all right let's do temperature around
120 or so
so we're gonna pull it garlic bread goes
in crank the temperature up to like 350
degrees
so i'm gonna get the pan heated with a
little bit of oil this is the steak
after it's been cooked
in the oven it doesn't look too great
right the surface is kind of gray
the inside i promise you is pink all the
way through only thing that's missing
is a nice beautiful crust jacket i'm
gonna stop talking so we can cook the
steak because this pan is really hot
look at that we're going to do
a flip look at that so we gotta go in
with everything the butter the rosemary
the garlic this honestly
smells ridiculous right up in here so
we're gonna do is we're gonna move this
to the top so it doesn't overcook
and this is the best part you take all
these little good bits
put it on top of the steak and you base
look at that
what this does is that infuses the
surface of the steak with all these
great flavors
that's just that's just so awesome all
right so we don't want to overcook it so
we're going to take this
we're going to render the fat on the
side we want to get as much out of it as
we can
all right let's stop cooking it and
let's take it out don't forget about the
stuff in the pan as the steak rests
i like to actually fry this garlic
everything is just gonna come together
pretty awesome
first you gotta slice along the
curvature
of this bone as close to the bone as
possible so we don't lose any of that
delicious meat
all right so here we go look at
this oh man look at this y'all missing
out
now go in with all the pieces transfer
that
fan it out for presentation follow the
way the bone is going around it
smells amazing it looks amazing garnish
a little bit of rosemary this is amazing
garlic butter that's still left in here
we're going to take a little bit
and our garlic bread let's cut this up
there you have it 50-minute reverse
seared
bone-in rabbi with garlic butter and
cheesy garlic bread
i'm going to need a few moments if you
have five hours and really want to make
something special
this is in my personal opinion the best
cut
of steak it is called the rib eye cap
it's like if filet mignon and ribeye had
like a baby
it's super super tender but actually has
a lot of fat and a lot of flavor
if you have a lot of time and you want
to make something really special this is
the perfect steak for that i'm gonna
season this with some salt and pepper
both sides this is like usually a pretty
thick steak it's got like three c's in
it so you gotta season a lot
make sure you don't miss any of the
sides we're going to be cooking the
steak sous-vi
and suvi is basically a term that
describes cooking food
at a very low temperature in a
circulating water bath because the
temperature is so low
it's going to take a long time this is a
machine that will essentially
circulate the water as well as maintain
temperature at whatever you want it to
be
i'm going to set this machine to 126
fahrenheit and it's going to cook for
four hours because we have a lot of time
to give this steak a lot of love and
attention
we're gonna go make some other stuff to
go with it we're gonna make a red wine
sauce to go with the steak you don't
need the most expensive wine ever just
make sure that
it is a wine that you like to drink
first thing you gotta do
gotta pour yourself a glass of this will
be
your cooking companion cheers to steak
one and a half cups of wine save the
rest
for yourself and you're also gonna do
equal parts beef stock so
another one and a half cups nice white
sauce pan
over medium medium-high heat until it
starts to bubble
and it's going to reduce by half while
we wait for the wine sauce to cook we're
just gonna
drink some more wine this is how i like
to enjoy my weekends a couple
tablespoons of flour
i'm gonna throw them some softened
butter mash it together
and kind of get it evenly incorporated
until it becomes a paste
get your whisk ready and because your
sauce is almost there
you take a big spoonful of this and
you're gonna want to whisk like
immediately so we're gonna go in and
we're just going to
get in there you want to make sure there
are no lumps because
it ain't that kind of sauce it's getting
really nice and bright
and thick in color now i think it's time
to season so we're going to first add a
couple tablespoons of brown break this
down
two no lumps again kind of want to
season the salt and you want to season
the taste
really important to keep tasting as
you're going
oh it's good this is pretty much there
i'm gonna take this off the heat
final thing that we're gonna do is add
more butter
because more butter is more better and
the butter also helps
cool the sauce down and if you're on a
diet
probably should have stopped watching
this video like three minutes ago silky
smooth
red wine sauce i'm gonna set this aside
and we're gonna work on some potatoes
while the steak cooks we're gonna make
some creamy mashed potatoes got about a
pound of really nice golden potatoes
first we're just gonna
cook them until they're super tender
10-15 minutes see you guys when you're
soft
all right bye-bye so the potatoes are
ready i'm gonna scoop oh god i'm gonna
scoop them out into a bowl to mash
so you just really gotta get in there
keep going ham until
we know that there's no lumps left
smashing these potatoes in itself
is already a great workout so now this
may seem like
a lot of butter and the reason for that
is because
it is if you're making this for a
special someone just do not tell them
how much butter you put
in it and do not let them see this video
my favorite part
yeah make it rain butter and look just
like magic
the butter is seemingly disappearing
into the potatoes
gotta go pretty ham i'm also gonna add
some milk to give it really creamy i'm
just going to season to taste
so we're going to pass it through a
sieve to make sure this is ultra creamy
let's get all this into here
pass this through pretty much all of it
has come out
look at that look at how silky that is
so these are done and the steak's pretty
much ready this steak has now
been in the water for about four hours
internal temperature
is around 125 126 so we're just going to
take this
on some paper towels it doesn't look
very appetizing right it's kind of brown
it's kind of gray
this is not how it's going to look in
the final form so we're just going to
pat
this dry moisture is your enemies dry
the surface as much as possible to get
that really hard sear i'm gonna heat our
oil this pan is smoking it's ready for
the meat
i'm gonna go ahead and do my favorite
part which is sear the steak
yeah this is already cooked all the way
through
so the only thing that we're trying to
do now is get a really nice super golden
brown crust this will need us here for
only like 20 seconds per side
and that's gonna be it for the steak
let's take a look
let's go all right flip look at that
crust
gotta make sure we get the sides as well
so we're gonna take this guy out
let him rest you know we've got a lot of
nice beef fat just gonna throw in some
asparagus a little bougie vegetable and
toss that in the beef fat
can't let all that flavor go to waste
some salt
some pepper
i'm gonna take that out hang out over
here and we're getting close so we have
our wonderful potatoes our red wine
sauce
make sure you have like everything ready
because time to cut the steak
so there's actually a string use clean
kitchen scissors to cut the string off
take it out all right that's the string
let's cut this steak
look at that this is the best day
ever this last piece oh my god look at
this steak and i think it's time to
plate
if you need to you can rewarm the
potatoes or the sauce in the microwave
or in the pan
if you're spending five hours on a steak
you might as well go all out
and every one of these sides really does
help take that steak to the next level
the red wine sauce just brings that nice
acidity and sweetness
got the creaminess from the mashed
potatoes nice snap and crunch from the
asparagus
of course the star of the show the steak
all that rich beefiness and juiciness
just really goes together with
everything that's on the plate
yes there it is this
is our five hour prime rib eye cap with
creamy mashed potatoes grilled asparagus
and a red wine sauce
i'll so you guys later whether you have
five minutes
50 minutes or even five hours to cook
steak is something i think that you can
enjoy at home no matter what
so hopefully the three dishes that we
made today show you that no matter how
busy or chill your day might be
there is always time to cook and until
next time
peace
[Music]
you